on peut y réfléchir tranquillement dis
moi si tu trouves que je vais trop vite
pour toi pourquoi est ce que quelqu un
tueur est un livreur de pizza comment la
ssa ssins pouvait savoir qu'il allait
tuer ça pas de sens parfait je pense que
tu tiens ton discours pour le grand
patron il ya eu un meurtre dans ma
circonscription
on a entendu des coups de feu dans la
rue ou d'un meurtre de musulmans non et
si on voyait juste comme un être humain
qui s'est fait abattre en pleine rue
alors
ils essaient de tous nos cours c'est
notre mode de vie qu'ils veulent
détruire donc votre frère auraient été
tués de façon délibérée
parce qu il savait que sam spade émail
five nous pensons qu'il pourrait y avoir
des risques pour la sécurité nationale
il y avait d'autres informations mais il
refuse de partager les leurs
ou doit rendre des comptes à tout le
monde et on a d'ascendance aux personnes
les gens ne croient plus aux options et
c'est exactement pour les raisons que
vous me donnez non c'est une simple
question mersey j'ai besoin d'avoir les
nerfs
on va devoir négocier vos vêtements vous
faites des paris sur l'affairé
il s'agit de la vie d'être mon père
avait une vision des choses
intéressantes
il disait si tu quittes une institution
sans la moindre amertume c'est que tu en
sors vainqueur qui tue sa mère c'est que
l'institution d'afrique
je vous offre une chance j'y voyais à
l'occasion de faire quelque chose de
bien
[Musique]